add olive oil to a hot pan and fry  finely chopped onions and red and green  peppers  then chop garlic and chilli and cook  until soft  Chili's weren't brilliant with eggs  given the dish a lovely hot kick next  add fresh chopped tomatoes then cumin  seeds and fry until the seeds are  fragrant and the tomatoes are lovely and  soft season next make wells in your  spicy sauce and crack in your eggs  then cover and cook on a low heat for  five minutes  so the whites are set and the yolks are  still lovely and runny to finish sly  spring onions and coriander and simply  sprinkle over  fresh spicy and deliciously different  easy North African eggs ready in under  20 minutes and this worth getting up  late for add the shin back into the pan  with a glass of dry white wine and the  juice of an orange look at that you got  that nice crispy skin on top you can see  how much of the stock has evaporated